so john let's start with you what did
you think about
ted cruz and also uh kind of this 87
year old senator just coming in
with like uh ax and cutting down trees
left and right
yeah ted cruz gets it right he's not
only
playing the part of what he believes but
he's also playing into
the um bitcoin like economy and the
bitcoin uh i guess like ecosystem right
of all the people that
are backing bitcoin he understands that
um
the rule itself i think is dumb i think
this
this amendment should have passed
everything that goes along with that
people have been they've been cutting
products and everything to kind of
in preparation for this regulation right
so bitcoin's almost kind of regulated
itself
making sure they cut down leverage
people's leverage that they you can't i
mean people are doing like 20x 100x
leverage
100x baby but they you see that in other
industries as well
yeah i think the big piece here is the
free market as we talked about yesterday
with the
wage prices continue to increase because
the free market takes care of it
what they're talking about here is
they're not trying to actually solve a
problem like this is my biggest
i think issue with it is if a if a
government or a politician walked in and
said okay
we have a problem let's go ahead and
solve the problem then
they would actually end up probably
making better rules than they are so
an example here would be the problem
they're trying to solve is how do we
drive
revenue to pay for this bill okay
we think that we can go into the crypto
world and do that
okay well guess what there's already
rules in place they're not
increasing the rules all they're doing
is they're saying hey we're really
serious about this and we're gonna try
to
better put a clear definition around it
so people know when to pay taxes and
when not
generally a good idea but the fact that
they basically
wrote laws that they don't understand
the industry
leads to incredible mistakes
and also just shows the arrogance of an
industry
right uh plano what do you think did you
just call me joe
no i thought about it though call me joe
guys my name is on my
on my oh
how do you know their names are john and
pelina wait show everybody
i did so so if you go she's she's a
rookie she doesn't know how to lean the
other way it's the other way
so if you get confused it's right here
so here's
here's my problem with this and and you
know
it's not necessarily an age problem
because there's plenty of older people
who understand that
you don't just stifle innovation because
there's something you don't understand
you just learn more about it i think
it's embarrassing for the united states
where
other people are watching from other
countries to look at the conversations
they're having in the laws they're
trying to pass
and be like oh look at the united states
stifling innovation
over something they know nothing about
and not even trying to hide the fact
that they don't understand it
um it says here the senate's average age
is 64.3 years old
older than the houses 58.4 years
and among us investors over 50 years old
76
say they have never even heard of
cryptocurrencies
joe you're fired you're fired
but i do want to make a personal note
here um
the other day for example so so i think
i think as an
older person you just need to have a
self-awareness of like maybe i don't
understand technology
as much as i think i do if this bill
wasn't up for debate
when do you think the timeline would be
for regulations and taxes to be passed
in the crypto like
crypto's already pretty heavily
regulated in my mind but
this is obviously going to increase the
taxes and the regulations around crypto
when do you think that timeline
would have been we need to have a
serious conversation in this country and
here's what everyone needs to hear
the bitcoin and cryptocurrency industry
is
over-regulated compared to the
traditional market here's
two great examples the first is in the
capital of finance on wall street in new
york city
if i want to start a financial firm i
have to go
and i have to create a business i have
to go through all the llc
type corporate creation i then have to
go get things
like a registered investment advisor or
maybe a broker dealer license or a money
transmitter license i have to do kyc
and aml these are all standard
regulatory requirements depending on the
business line i want to go into
if i want to create a crypto business
in the state of new york in new york
city on wall street the
financial capital of the world i have to
go do every single one of those same
things i have to create a legal entity
i have to go and get the required
regulatory
approvals or licenses things like broker
dealer licenses money transmitter
licenses etc
i have to do kyc and aml but i also have
to go get
an additional license called a bit
license and that bit license has only
been given to a handful of companies
and therefore regulators in the state of
new york are
actually being able to play king maker
so in the financial capital of the world
it is harder to start a crypto company
than it is a traditional financial
company
the banks may not support your bank
account they may literally take down
your bank account
you may not be able to use traditional
services like stripe
or others depending on if you are in a
crypto business on top of that you may
not be able to advertise your business
on certain platforms
like facebook or google depending on if
you're a crypto company or not
so there is more regulation and also
more obstacles and complexity to running
a crypto business
in the financial capital of the world
than a traditional financial business
so from a business perspective if you
run a crypto company
you have more regulatory hurdles to jump
over than a traditional financial
business
that's not how it should be it should be
an even playing field and if we're
serious about
innovation in this country we should
even the playing field between the
incumbents
and the challengers on top of that a
second example
is that if i go to dinner tonight john
and i go
rip some mcdonald's and i pay for dinner
with us dollars
i simply buy the meal and i pay sales
tax
and i'm happy to do that because that's
what's required of me by my government
but if i was to not use us dollars as
the currency and instead use the digital
currency of
bitcoin i not only would pay for the
meal
and the sales tax but i would also be
required
to pay capital gains tax on that bitcoin
purchase and so what ends up happening
is whether i'm running a business
or operating as an individual trying to
use a digital currency as a medium of
exchange
i am actually taxed more aggressively
for using the digital currency
so the mainstream narrative that this
industry
is not regulated is false this industry
is actually regulated more than the
traditional market
and so if we are serious about creating
innovation in this country
and creating economic prosperity and
creating jobs and making sure we are the
leader on a global stage
we must even the playing field the
traditional financial firms
must not have an advantage in the market
compared to the challengers
imagine if when competitors
to let's say microsoft or ibm
or any of the other incumbents today
actually had to go through
more regulatory hurdles to start their
business
you are in fact protecting the
incumbents
what you are doing is you are allowing
them to continue
to use that degree of separation because
of the regulatory barrier
and allowing them to survive even though
the free market may determine them not
to be the best thing
for the end user and so if we want to
serve users if we want to serve
consumers
if we want to create change and make
sure that the best products
and the best services are built here in
america we have to
even the playing field there is no
under regulation the industry actually
has
more hurdles to overcome than less that
is the truth
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it